estamos aquí en la galería nacional de
arte en washington dc y estamos
observando venus consolando al amor una
obra de françois bücher del año 1751 y
es una confitura vaya que si estamos
aquí observando a venus ocupando una
línea diagonal en el centro del lienzo
la cual nos recuerda que viene en el
barroco aunque aunque esto ya es estilo
rococó aquí vemos hermosa y elegante
venus tiene su brazo izquierdo cruzando
su cuerpo intentando robar las flechas
de cupido para que para que no haga a
través sur ha escupido haciendo que
otras personas se enamoren vemos también
la chispa del deseo que emana su mirada
de cupido y aquí los colores verdes
suaves colores azules rosas colores que
le asociamos al estilo rococó vemos que
también existen una disposición de
suspender la credibilidad y crear una
fantasía crear un espacio de ensueño un
espacio onírico en el estilo rococó
también observa el paisaje el paisaje
está en y
de foco tenemos este árbol grande en el
centro un poco al fondo a la derecha
pero puedes observar que en realidad no
hay un verdadero espacio entre los
elementos de la pintura no hay una
verdadera construcción de distancia
entre los elementos está como evocando a
la naturaleza ya los paisajes vemos
vemos un tipo de expresión de
indulgencia de riqueza de amor y de
deseo y esto fue comisionado por madame
de pompadour la amante del rey también
existe la posibilidad se ha pensado que
posiblemente fue ella quien posó para
venus ella era una mujer muy muy
idealizada y tiene mucho que ver con los
intereses de los intereses del momento
esto fue un periodo antes de la
revolución francesa fue un periodo en el
que en el que la pintura el estilo
rococó se preocupaba por la emoción por
el tipo de indulgencia se preocupaba por
los placeres por los placeres del cuerpo
y aquí lo podemos apreciar muy bien en
françois bücher su obra venus consolando
al amor 1751